Tony decopo is anchoring our election
coverage in Florida Tony good morning
there is a lot going on especially where
you are at what's going on
yeah hey good morning guys if you love
election day I got good news for you
it's here and if you want it all to end
I got good news for you as well it'll be
over soon there is a lot going on the
polls are already open here in Miami the
big city behind me and there's a little
bit of rain moving in weather is one of
the many variables that could affect
turnout and turnout is everything in
this election but by the way guys every
single voter in America has at least one
race to vote on today everybody hearing
my voice right now and the results
they're going to shape at least the next
two years of all of our Lives what we do
with the economy with inflation the
Border crime access to abortion and so
many other issues we haven't even
imagined yet because they haven't come
up it's going to tell us something about
where we want to go as a country right
now and also and this is important how
much we still trust our elections to
bring us there so Nate you're right it
is a very big day and we've got reports
ahead from states that could make all
the difference in this election but
we're going to begin actually with the
closing arguments from President Joe
Biden and former president Donald Trump
and what's at stake in their own words
this election is not a referendum it's a
choice
it's a choice between two very different
visions of America Joe Biden closed out
the midterms
very much like he started them we know
in our bones and our democracy is at
risk and we know that this is your
moment to defend it and for those less
worried about democracy than the value
of their dollar he touted relief we're
shipping America made products overseas
instead of shipping American jobs
overseas
but two years after Democrats won the
White House and Congress promising
economic Revival and National Unity
Republicans say they failed under the
Trump Administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world with
no inflation
Biden and the democrat congress created
the worst inflation in 50 years for days
now former president Donald Trump the
man many blame for Republican losses
last election has once again been
leading the call for a red wave on
Tuesday and if you want to stop the
destruction of our country and save the
American dream then tomorrow you must
vote Republican in a giant red wave and
history suggests he's gonna get it too
in the 22 midterm elections from 1934 to
2018 the president's party has averaged
a loss of 28 House Seats and four Senate
seats and has gained seats in both
Chambers only twice going into election
day the latest CBS Battleground tracker
estimates that Republicans could indeed
retake the house needing to net only
five seats for control they could get
more than double that but the Senate is
a very different different story and it
could go either way Pennsylvania Georgia
Arizona Wisconsin and Nevada all our
statistical ties toss-ups in other words
just hours to go before the voting ends
and while voting for this election is
not yet over some including the former
president seem to already be looking
ahead to 2024. I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th
and we will see what that very big
announcement is next week I think you
could probably guess what it is but
let's stick with today while we're
living through today because it always
does come down to turnout of course
money too by the way an estimated 16
billion dollars has already been poured
into these races that is a national
record it is the equivalent if you do
your calculations by Powerball jackpots
of eight Powerball jackpots and all of
it is just to get your interest America
and push you to exercise your right to
vote so think about that for a moment
and remember there's only one poll that
really matters and that's the one being
taken today at The Ballot Box so get
ready Mark yours